[Music]
in cheesy neighbor news submitted by
Casso and women's year-long Feud years
long feud with a smelly cheese shop and
zinc Court ruling yeah mm-hmm pretty
bored some cheese shops smelled really
bad so she smells yeah I mean like
you're in your house like it was that
bad though probably that it was like
punching through her walls did you smell
that cheese plate last night from Costco
no I did not
whatever kind of jeez that was a like
[Music]
big like wherever I go I want to try
what that country is known for and I've
ate some pretty crazy [ __ ] or in was it
Sweden or Switzerland Switzerland I'm
all coolies they're like everyone's like
you got trying to find you that's what
they're leaning on for and it's just
like a bunch of melted cheese that's
like pouring from a waterfall and then
the minute I opened the door I walked in
first time so the heat is on to the
heater yes [ __ ] I've never felt that way
about walking shouldn't our restaurant
really yeah I'm the same way because I
weird bomb was recently and I had a
bacon Barbie cheeseburger delicacy oh
that's the connection I was like you eat
up from the barbeque know their cuisine
there I assume and fries a head fries
they were I'm afraid though I'm afraid
waffle waffle waffle wow how very
authentic dude
yeah right yeah they had this yellow
mustard that you got to try why yellow
when you go yeah yeah well yellow it's
completely yellow did they have this
thing called catsup no no okay
all right so this takes place in Germany
and there's this woman who owns a hat
shop and and so downstairs
she has she's neighbors with this cheese
shop it sounds like an old-timey village
like my hat shop was next to the cheese
shop in Germany everything yeah so four
years
she has said that like you know her
entire place in her whole hat shop just
and my hats are stinky now yeah the Chi
and so she's saying that the smell is
seeping through the windows a staircase
and even electrical sockets
what you smell in the sockets there too
yeah so there's a pizza shop typically
stocks over 200 types of cheese and ages
around 3 tons of it oh [ __ ] this is a
manufacturer yeah so they're saying that
ever since 2016 she has been putting up
signs showing you like a warning sign
and a nose on the shops windows and so
pretty much saying like this is a stinky
cheese shop or whatever and so then
that's when the cheese shop said that
those signs have been damaging the shops
reputation and this has been damaging a
reputation so then she took the cheese
shop to courts over her right to display
the signs but recently the court ruled
that she can't display the signs but
really could continue to speak about how
much the store smells because it's both
an expression of opinion any
representation of facts to say that a
house of over to cheese shop smells like
cheese yeah this story is funny that was
a real court hearing yeah you may not
put any to do a gag order but you may
gag the smell this village is so cute
this is like the trial of the century
the village like there's a court case
going like I'm so going to live above
the chocolates yeah yes so then she's
really happy with the outcome cuz she's
like well I still say how much you think
the open the windows you're like steak
I was saying like how is she she's just
having a recording that's playing like
all the time it's like my cam like a
megaphone
sheek shiek also a blanket to hang on
the window that says it stinks
exclamation point sign it's a blanket
sign he doesn't no no no just use the
different mediums I understand hearing
me and Nikki are so petty though man if
we were above this lady oh we would we
would we would open up oops
I would open up oops store immediately
yeah we start we have an artist poop
store here just trying to sell off
product I picked you like a farmer's
like outfit and like oh like plastic
overalls like yeah and I'm like Jana I
am here take your time out of my poop's
job I made some this morning and I have
some delivery it's about to be yellow
poop season so I really can't be here
for long business oh yes it's not like
dude I wonder it I wonder who was here
first
was it the cheese shop or with the hat
shop because if it was the hat shop I'd
be pissed in my head it they opened at
the same time and at first they were
friends they were like hello opening
business yes yes we are
but cheese and of cheese and over time
they slowly got enraged lovely cheese
you've got remember they started off
like Swiss cheese
oh cheese don't smell yeah it starts
gonna stinky in the station they're like
we're gonna introduce a new line next
week [ __ ] those cheese's
now it's 200 times of Jesus three tonnes
but they actually like yeah it's crazy
the age you know which what part of
Germany oh isn't it southern Germany bad
Helen Broome cheese just like aged milk
yeah more or less like curds
yeah with different types of like
bacteria yeah that are like molding in
it sometimes and they don't they like
traditionally like aged it in like a
stomach lining of yeah yeah that's nasty
man goat cheeses [ __ ] bomb that's
true I like all kinds of cheese you know
what are those cheeses baby huh baby
bell oh yeah those are [ __ ] bomb son
I like cheese with red wine it's pretty
good yeah happy tooth and crackers I
only like two types of cheese brie and
goat cheese it's like so gooey one oh I
like that one too well we have it at
every one of our parties you probably
have it oh because either than that I
don't eat dairy really true I think I
could go forever I'm eating dairy but
brie cheese gets me really every time a
Mexican food cheese has like the [ __ ]
ingredient yeah like I cannot go without
cheese me yeah I don't like that cheese
did you like the crumbly was it called
no cheese no oh but because the one that
smells like B right yeah he's very salty
good it smell it smells better tastes
good yeah I can't get past the smell
he's too much of the taste though it's
like no hand in hand it's like the
stinky tofu like I can't I just I can't
that really smells like [ __ ] though yeah
human feces you guys like Havarti what
is that
as far as the cheese I like it a lot no
it's premium
okay creamy it's uh it's good a good of
sack goes more they were saying cream
you also cream anymore just him saying
it like when speaking about a food I'm
still cream I agree with you what
character is this like soft guy right
now [ __ ] that guy
I'm just being open about the
charcuterie board everyone could look
like an [ __ ]
no man being open about my feelings
cheese it's 2019 right now what are you
feeling right now hmm
I'm feeling like you know 2019 / 2020
and I just feel as a man I'm being
emasculated but it's okay so you're
entering the new decade being
emasculated mmm
watch time it's very tight I like it
he's so passive right now it's no fun if
he's not fighting back it won't last for
long
push the right button yeah I'll find it
oh you will out of all people you will
find it I just thought it was fun that
we're all talking about our favorite
cheese's and I was just trying to open
up the opening you go you can't eat very
much he spends the whole night in the
bathroom so unlike his birthday we have
a rule like he can't you know Mexican
food yeah like she loves Mexican food
eats it like good to have sex beforehand
or no sex like you poop in the bathroom
too long are you I get like a tummy ache
he gets a tummy ache my little tummy
hurts you have to rub his tummy find the
[ __ ] button sweet I'm trying I
thought I was constipated I'd like to
think that she would help rub my tummy
but yeah right trying to work this [ __ ]
out of your belt she doesn't want to
[ __ ] something she's got a rub there's
me he wouldn't even tell me because he's
so private about that he won't like talk
about pooping ever I'm sensitive in 2020
yeah oh so you're talking about pooping
I hope we talk about pooping in 20 yeah
[Laughter]
how hard was it when you had the whole
kidney stones to talk to her then were
you trying to keep that like it was I'm
gonna try to like suck it I was like
[ __ ] about it too much honestly no but
he did cry and like he never cries
that's not called bitching either
it's just called sharing yeah
Payne Wow cool story we just finished
paying off those bills today
[Music]
[Music]